invité de notre journal monsieur robert
badinter monsieur badinter vous n'avez
pas encore parlé sur toutes ces affaires
vous êtes ce soir ici au titre de
spécialiste en tout cas d'un décret d'un
écrivain d'un homme qui a beaucoup écrit
sur ces problèmes de la communauté juive
en france sur les problèmes du judaïsme
ce matin on entendu deux discours celui
du grand rabbin qui disait justement ne
disons pas n'importe quoi sur ces
affaires gardons la raison on a entendu
aussi aujourd'hui madame simone veil qui
disait je ne veux montrer personne du
doigt avant de savoir ce qui s'est
exactement passé qui sont les criminels
est ce que vous pensez vous qu'il faut
globalisé comme l'ont fait certains pour
dire qu'il ya vraiment eu une montée du
de de l'antisémitisme en france et puis
du racisme aussi je crois d'abord que le
grand rabbin une raison
il faut raison garder et par exemple ce
que nous avons vu tout à l'heure ces
violences commises par ces jeunes juifs
et bien je verrai prouve absolument et
je considère qu'ils ne nuisent à la
cause qu'il croit servir
raison garder il faut quand même prendre
la mesure de ce qui s'est passé
indiscutablement une escalade n'est ce
pas
quand on voit des actes de cette nature
il faut bien mesurer la démarche on
serait venu je parle des auteurs de ces
sections abominable ils se réunissent
ils réfléchissent ils préparent leur
horrible mise en scène ils réunissent
les instruments ils parc la nuit ils
ouvrent les tombeaux il passe le
cercueil ils sortent grave je m'arrête
là mais réfléchissez à tous ces actes
commis les uns après les autres de sang
froid et comment ne pas se dire ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire ça où
s'arrêteront ils donc il est certain
qu'on est en présence d'un racisme à
l'état pur il est certain que même si
vous êtes là devant un acte
inqualifiable
on ne doit pas généraliser oui je le dis
très clairement
très fortement
pas une seconde on ne voit pas de
globaliser on ne doit pas nous paralyser
trop de gens à la fois du soyons encore
plus direct disons le très clairement la
france n'est pas un pays antisémite
l'antisémitisme n'a pas sa loi sa place
en france mais il y a dix antisémites et
des racistes en france et nous avons vu
là quelques alors face à ce problème que
peut-on faire est-ce que vous pensez que
il est nécessaire de légiférer de faire
des lois ou bien à elle bien ça ne
servira à rien ça peut même avoir là
aussi des effets pervers non c'est pas
moi qui via jamais que les lois on peut
avoir des effets pervers non et
simplement je veux bien marquer d'une
part que l'état de droit en lui même ne
peut pas être l'état de faiblesse je
veux dire par là qu'il faut appliquer
fermement la loi mais que dans des
problèmes comme celui là le vrai débat
la vraie question et s'inscrit dans le
coeur dans les consciences et ce dont il
s'agit essentiellement de demain une
manifestation il faut y aller il faut
qu'on voie le maximum de gens unis dans
leur refus de ce racisme qui qui
risquent de déshonorer la france est aux
yeux de l'étranger aussi mais au delà
c'est le travail d'éducation c'est la
quête obscur constante de la vérité
c'est le courage de dire la vérité celle
au courage de rappeler qu' il y a eu des
crimes contre l'humanité et qu'on a tué
des femmes des hommes des enfants
rappelez vous les enfants d'izieu
simplement parce qu'ils étaient juifs
imaginez simplement parce qu'ils étaient
juifs il devait mourir de la même façon
qu'on est allé sortir ce corps pourquoi
de cette terre de provence parce qu'il
était juif et là vous touchez du doigt
la réalité insupportable du racisme et
qu'il faut combat après je suis content
que milliers de toutes parts ces
protestations merci monsieur bérard